life becomes easier when you delete the
unnecessary people from it
life doesn't always give Second Chances
take the first one
live to be happy and be happy to be
alive
the only life worth living is the one
you're passionate about
[Music]
be grateful for what you have and your
life will reward you with more
life is a challenge meet it
[Music]
to live a creative life we must lose our
fear of being wrong
[Music]
what we do in life echoes in eternity
the hard part is not making a decision
it's living with it
[Music]
life is like photography you use the
negatives to develop foreign
[Music]
that someone ruined with the truth
life is full of open doors but some need
to be shut
[Music]
the drama of life begins with a whale
and ends with a sigh
life is ten percent what happens to you
and ninety percent how you respond to it
life is what you make it
in the end it's not the years in your
life that count it's the life in your
years
[Music]
your time is limited don't waste it
living someone else's life
you get out of life what you have the
courage to ask for
[Music]
God gave us the gift of life it is up to
us to give ourselves the gift of living
well
[Music]
in three words I can sum up everything
I've learned about life it goes on
to live is the rarest thing in the world
most people simply exist
you can never plan the future by living
in the past
[Music]
we make a living by what we get we make
a Life by what we give
[Music]
all life is an experiment
the more experiments you make the better
you only live once but if you do it
right once is enough
[Music]
life ought to be a struggle of Desire
toward Adventures whose nobility will
fertilize the soul
[Music]
the greatest mistake you can make in
life is to be continually fearing you
will make a mistake
life is not a problem to be solved it is
a reality to be experienced
you can't live your life for other
people you've got to do what's right for
you even if it hurts some people you
love
I've come to believe that all my past
failure and frustration were actually
laying the foundation for the
understandings that have created the new
level of living I now enjoy
thank you
life's wisdom can often miss us because
life moves so fast that we have to
practice standing still
[Music]
life is inherently risky there is only
one big risk you should avoid at all
costs
the risk of doing nothing
[Music]
only a life lived for others is a life
worthwhile
greatest day in your life and mind is
when we take total responsibility for
our attitude
that's the day we truly grow up
[Music]
everyone in life is gonna hurt you you
just have to figure out which people are
worth the pain
no one ever finds life worth living one
has to make it worth living
[Music]
accept responsibility for your life know
that it is you who will get you where
you want to go no one else
an unexamined life is not worth living
[Music]
life is much more fun if you live it in
the spirit of play and collaboration
working with instead of against others
life is a succession of lessons that
must be lived to be understood
things change friends leave life doesn't
stop for anybody
live life to the fullest and focus on
the positive
[Music]
I've failed over and over and over again
in my life that is why I succeed
life is a question how we live it is the
answer
today is life the only life you were
sure of make the most of today
life takes on meaning when you become
motivated set goals and charge after
them in an Unstoppable manner
life is not a matter of holding good
cards but sometimes playing a poor hand
well
singleness of purpose is one of the
chief Essentials for success in life no
matter what one's aim may be
each of us experiences defeats in life
we can transform defeat into Victory if
we learn from life's failures
there are three constants in life change
choice and principles
I think of Life as a good book the
further you get into it the more it
begins to make sense
there's no life as complete as the life
that is lived by choice
life is not about how fast you run or
how high you climb but how well you
bounce
don't search for the meaning of life
simply be present for the people you
love
each life is made up of mistakes and
learning waiting and growing practicing
patience and being persistent
life is simple but we insist on making
it complicated
life isn't complicated if you don't lose
your concentration on your true vision
[Music]
wake up to realities real life is all
about real things
[Music]
life is like a roller coaster you will
have your ups and downs you just need to
get over it
life is a lively process of becoming
[Music]
in order to write about life you must
first live it
the whole secret of a successful life is
to find out what is one's Destiny to do
and then to do it
[Music]
life is a flower of which love is the
honey
[Music]
life is a mountain your goal is to find
your path not to reach the top
[Music]
do not take life too seriously you will
never get out of it alive
is like a box of chocolates you never
know what you're gonna get
believe that life is worth living and
your belief will make it so
[Music]
which way you choose to see your life in
the future depends on your attitude
today
each person must live their life as a
model for others
[Music]
life often teaches us through our wrong
turns and missed opportunities
[Music]
life is under no obligation to give us
what we expect
[Music]
live as if you were to Die Tomorrow
learn as if you were to live forever
[Music]
if you want to live a happy life tie it
to a goal not to people or objects
[Music]
the happiness of your life depends upon
the quality of your thoughts
you will face many defeats in your life
but never let yourself be defeated
the two most important days in your life
are the day you were born and the day
you find out why
life is short break the rules forgive
quickly kiss slowly love truly laugh
uncontrollably and never regret anything
that makes you smile
[Music]
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments